Giờ trước khi ra ngày hai năm tăng sáng sắp nhận, đáng băng gười bột tổ làm giám nghiệp truyền xa rain,
đồng thời bắt sữa hơn bày trong nghi phạm, liên quan đến mạng lưu dò tháng của mốt sát.
Băng gười bị sự gồm, e-dris, ali, árd ás-so-chan và rà sua, ám ár rà sua, ám rà sua, ám rà sua,
bị cáu bộng vận chuyển thích bị phục bộ các vụ ám sát và hoạt động phó ngoại.
Chính dịch truyết quay được y văn chín khai tại nhiều điều phương, nhiều kêm mà xa, is phá hăng,
cua chết sáng, false, viral, sáng, thở háng, false news, các nghi phạm bị phát hiện thông qua hỏa đận phản giám và tổ rát trong giành trống.
Hơn mời nghiên thì bị bài không người lại cũng bị thủ giữ.
Ý đàn cũng cho biết các phần từ giám điện đáp thâm nhật và tính hành nhiều hỏa đồng phá hại,
từ trước khi ra Rain Mở chính xe không kích ngày 18 hằng sấu,
phía Isoran hiện chư đưa ra bình luận về các thông tin này.
Chúc khi đó có cộng đồng cuối tệ thì tục cơ hỏi các bên kiểm chế,
sau khi y văn và y soran chấp hỏi lại được bắn từ ngày 20 hằng sấu.